we're going to begin this hour with a
look at children and gun safety the
decision to charge the parents of the
alleged gunman in the oxford michigan
school shooting with involuntary
manslaughter has brought new attention
to the laws surrounding children's
access to firearms
gun safety advocates want gun owners to
be held criminally responsible in the
event that they fail to properly secure
their firearms and members of the
medical community are pushing for more
funding to treat gun injuries and deaths
as a public health emergency senior
medical correspondent that's dr tara
narula spoke with a trauma surgeon at
the center of that push along with three
parents who sadly lost children to
firearms tara this is such an important
conversation good morning to you good
morning gail those parents all say the
deaths of their children were
preventable gwen lacroix's son jonah
payne used an unlocked gun to take his
own life at age 17. kristen song's 15
year old son ethan was killed while
playing with a gun at a friend's house
mark barton's seven-year-old son daniel
died in the sandy hook school shooting
we were joined by dr chethan sathya
director of northwell health's center
for gun violence prevention
this isn't something that happened to us
this is our life now i often say that i
feel like my dna has been rewired since
i was shot to death waiting for the er
doctor to come in we had no idea ethan
had been shot i thought he had gotten
hit by a car i was afraid of it for a
long time because jonah struggled with
his mental health i didn't
fight hard enough i didn't take a stand
and say there are not going to be any
unlocked guns in my home the gun jonah
accessed was registered to gwen
lacroix's then husband who confirmed to
cbs news that it was stored unlocked and
unloaded in a separate part of the house
from the bullets and in compliance with
michigan law whether you're talking
about accidental injuries or firearm
related
suicide either one is an exploration for
a younger kid or another thing is an
impulsive behavior and why is it that we
have
you know mental health issues in other
countries like canada europe
are no different than here but the
lethality when you have access to a
firearm is just exponentially higher
firearms are the leading cause of death
ages one to 19 and two-thirds of those
deaths are suicides it's estimated 13
million kids in the u.s live in a home
with at least one firearm
my son and his best friend
were posting to social media on a fake
account and the detective said there was
probably a hundred kids who knew
your son and his best friend were
playing with guns and said nothing
and that is why it is our job
to protect our children from themselves
following ethan's death in 2018 the song
family successfully lobbied for a
connecticut state law strengthening
requirements around safe storage of
firearms and homes opponents in the
state legislature called ethan's law too
broad but it passed with bipartisan
support and a federal version has been
introduced i was just asking basically
to step up and and make sure that
people cannot get a hold of unsecured
guns eight children are they are dying
because they've gained access to a gun
30 states and the district of columbia
have passed child access prevention laws
like ethan's law a similar measure was
working its way through the michigan
legislature at the time of the oxford
school shooting do you think that this
is something that is not on most parents
radar
i think it depends on where you live
yeah there are families who live with
this every day as part of their reality
and
unfortunately they're not getting the
support and the attention that
those of us who have
suffered high profile
tragedies for more than 20 years
federally funded research into gun
injury prevention was prohibited in 2019
congress lifted that ban dr sathya is
among the first to receive nih funding
to study the root causes of gun injury
and death obviously this is an area that
was not funded for a very long time
what did that do to our understanding of
firearm safety if you look at the
leading causes of death whether there be
heart disease motor vehicle collisions
cancer i mean firearms have always been
at the top and they receive like less
than one percent of the funding of those
other diseases i feel
frustrated
that we continue to come forward with
our stories
and
the inaction
continues to make jonah's loss
even worse than it already is our
research right now that's funded by the
nih is focused on asking every single
patient who comes into our hospital
questions related to firearm injury risk
and so we're actually using a model that
we use for substance use where we
started asking everybody
that's what helped normalize those
conversations and then if you screen
positive for access
you're going to get gun locks firearm
safety counseling and if you screen
positive for violence risk you're going
to get violence interrupters community
resources to hopefully break that cycle
of violence how do you feel about
gun ownership i have no problem if
someone owns a gun i'm against
negligent reckless behavior i would like
to see
there be consequences for gun-owning
adults who allow children to
get hold of their guns and either
hurt themselves or someone else i mean
we work with a ton of gun owners
gun-owning parents are even more
appreciative of having that conversation
because they really understand the
importance of safety i've found that
most gun owners that i speak to
identify as responsible gun owners i
mean all three of us it's a safe storage
issue and all three of our our
situations the gun could have been
stored in the time it takes you to take
one breath what have you learned about
the incidents that you've prevented
through sandy hook promise school
shootings
mass casualty events that someone says
something over social media or in
passing to somebody in school
if that individual is trained in our
safe something program they know exactly
what to do and they can tell trusted
adults who can get that person uh help
how do we
humanize this
and keep the faces of your children
present and all the children that have
been lost so that
it's not just about statistics and
numbers i i always have pictures of my
little daniel to look at the face of my
sweet little seven-year-old boy who was
innocently in his first grade classroom
when he was shot to death
if that doesn't resonate with you
my youngest james was three when jonah
died
um and he doesn't remember jonah it's
very difficult to grow through that and
to understand
and to not have that big brother
to guide you i really walk people
through ethan's day i want them to this
really feel
what it's like to have your son tell you
about all his hopes and dreams and then
you know
an hour later he's dead i want people to
watch the er doctor literally slide down
the wall and put his head in his hands
and whisper your son is gone
as a pediatric trauma surgeon who's had
to walk into that waiting room and
deliver news
impossible news to families
how does hearing this make you feel i
mean this is you know a preventable
crisis that we are doing nothing about
makes you feel helpless what do you hope
the legacy of your
children will be take a few minutes
to learn about our children
get to know them a little bit and
hopefully folks will understand
what's at stake
and
what what can be lost i'm working with
my community and really building up our
health care system to face this public
health crisis in the same way that we've
met the pandemic you know i always tell
people we don't get vacation from this
we there's no hump day there's no tji
friday you all will go home to your
lives you'll kiss your children we're
going to go home to an empty bedroom
all four of our panelists describe the
tremendous ripple effects including the
significant disability and chronic
injuries that come from non-fatal
firearm injuries and the psychological
damage to entire communities and
families including thoughts of suicide
and despair first thank you to those
parents for talking so candidly about
something that is so painful i was very
surprised here in your piece the leading
cause of death for children between the
ages of 1 to 19. and i've talked to i've
seen parents who have been in situations
where they've lost someone so tragically
anybody they say it's not about moving
on it's about moving forward what do
these parents say about how they get
through their days they were all so
compelling so strong and you know
kristen said the trauma is truly intense
and i think for them the strength comes
from the idea that they might save
another child the strength comes from
honoring the children that they lost and
also being there for their surviving
children you know their children have
helped pull them out of the darkness in
fact kristen told me you know she was
suicidal at one point and her surviving
son evan looked at her and said mom you
know you're not going to hurt yourself
are you because if you check out i'm
going to be right after you and you know
she said in that moment i realized i had
to survive and fight for my children and
my family so the ripple affects the
concentric circles it just goes on
yeah and the point was made that there
is not a tension between storing it
safely and getting access for the
reasons you have a gun in the first
place exactly important exactly doctor
thank you very much